حسنًا، أنا ملكة متوسطة الحجم، هذا
مظهر مثالي للمكتب متوسط ​​الحجم أقل من 100 دولار،
هذا هو أكبر ما يثير غيظ حيواني الأليف لكوني
فتاة متوسطة الحجم إذا كنت تبحث عن
إلهام للأزياء متوسطة الحجم، فتأكد من إعجابك
ومتابعتك في العامين الأخيرين فقط  منذ
سنوات، أصبح مصطلح الحجم المتوسط
موضوعًا ساخنًا على Tik Tok، إليك بعض
سيارات الدفع الرباعي متوسطة الحجم المفضلة لدي، ولا يشير هذا
إلى حجم سيارتك، حسنًا،
كوينز متوسطة الحجم المتعرجة، أشعر بالفخر حقًا
لأنني كنت من أوائل الأشخاص
لاستخدامه ولديك الكثير من النساء
والأشخاص فقط في المجتمع،
أشعر بأنهم ممثلون ومسموعون مع مليارات
المشاهدات حول الموضة متوسطة الحجم # لقد
خلق اتجاه Tik Tok مساحة لأصحاب
النفوذ مثل أوليفيا تيرني
لتقديم نصائح الموضة للجسم  النوع
الذي غالبًا ما يتم التغاضي عنه إذا كنت لا تشعر بأنك
ممثل في مجتمع الحجم الزائد
إذا كنت لا تشعر بأنك ممثل
في هذا النوع من الحجم المستقيم،
فمن المحتمل أنك في مكان ما في
الوسط لعقود من الزمن،
وقد انتهت خطوط الملابس ذات الحجم الكبير بشكل مستقيم  مع
حجم 12، سلطت الجهود المبذولة حول تضمين الحجم الضوء
إلى حد كبير على المقاسات الكبيرة للنساء
والتي تبدأ عادةً بمقاس 18
ولكن هذا غالبًا ما يتجاهل
نسبة كبيرة من النساء الأمريكيات اللاتي يقعن في
المنتصف. لم أر حقًا مقاسي
ممثلًا لذلك أردت  أن أكون ذلك
الشخص من أجل الناس، وقد نجح الأمر بالفعل في إثارة
إعجاب الناس بضع
مرات في الشهر، وسأصمم زيًا ويتم بيعه بالكامل، وعادةً ما يتم
بيعه
بالمقاس الدقيق الذي نتحدث عنه
كبير إضافي  - كبير مزدوج XL، يتم اختيار هذه المقاسات على
الفور وفقًا
لدراسة أجريت عام 2016، حيث يتراوح متوسط ​​حجم
المرأة الأمريكية بين 16 و18 عامًا، ولكن
منذ بداية
صناعة الأزياء الحديثة في القرن التاسع عشر،
تم تصميم الغالبية العظمى من الملابس
على
لا يزال تجار التجزئة ومصممو الأزياء
يريدون عارضات أزياء من المقاس Z إلى الحجم 4 يريدون
الشباب ويريدون أن يكونوا نحيفين للغاية
لأن هذا هو معيارهم للجمال
المثالي وهو أمر غير واقعي، هذه هي
صورتي من علامتي التجارية، وبالتالي سأبيع
فقط لأولئك الأشخاص الذين يناسبون تلك
الصورة  وهنا يأتي دور TI وهي
تحاول ارتداء الملابس لمتابعيها متوسطي الحجم
لتوضح لهم مدى ملاءمتهم للاهتمام
بالمحتوى الخاص بها، وهو أمر مرتفع للغاية لدرجة أن
هذه هي وظيفتها بدوام كامل الآن، وآمل أن
أكون الشخص الذي يمكنه عرض ما إذا
كنت تتسوق  في هذا المتجر، إليك
قياساتي وهذا هو الحجم الذي أنا
هنا فقط لمنح الناس
طريقة أسهل للتسوق، استخدم نجاحاتي
أو إخفاقاتي كمثال للمساعدة في توجيه
طريقهم عند النظر إلى تسويق العلامة التجارية التي
قد تشعر بها قليلاً  إن الانفصال عن
النظر إلى شخص مؤثر يشبه
نوع جسمك يشترك في حجم مماثل،
ورؤية كيف يبدو الزي متماسكًا، وكيف يتم
تصميم العنصر، فهو
يساعد حقًا في إنشاء اتصالات يتم فقدها
عندما تتسوق عبر الإنترنت فقط، وأعتقد أن
العلامات التجارية وتجار التجزئة هم  إن النضال من أجل
اللحاق بالعلامات التجارية وتجار التجزئة الذين
يتعاملون معها بنجاح
يكسبون هذا المستهلك، ويمكن للعلامات التجارية الراغبة في
الفوز بالمستهلكين متوسطي الحجم أن تسد
فجوة مربحة في السوق، لذلك إذا
حددنا السوق متوسطة الحجم بأحجام من 12 إلى
16، فإنك ترى في الواقع أن هذا يجعل  ما يزيد
عن 65 مليار دولار من حيث الحجم، وهو ما يمثل حوالي
نصف إجمالي سوق الملابس النسائية،
ولا ينبغي لنا أن ننقله إلى
قسم منفصل من المتجر، ولا ينبغي لنا أن
ننقل كل شيء عبر الإنترنت تريد
بيعه للجماهير، ثم ستحصل عليه
لتكييف استراتيجية عملك
لتشمل الحجم لأن
لكل شخص الحق في أن يكون عصريًا،
لذا ها أنت ذا، هذا
أنا